[Music]
all right
what a fun first episode that we just
had together with Sarah Ness there's a
lot of fun did it on both the authentic
revolution a lot of fun now well good a
little bit deeper for all those that
want to tune in so Sarah what would you
like to start us off with I was actually
really curious about you so I kind of
just like want to fire some questions at
you and at Ron if that's okay excellent
go for it
we'll see how long we're on sticks
around but yeah yeah yeah should I ask
him things first just in case okay I so
actually a question I have for both of
you okay I got the sense that like you
have a really strong underlying
philosophy to like why you do this show
and what you care about if you had to
like put the essence of that into words
like what do you care about or believe
such that house you want to do all this
work mm-hmm it's a very good question
hmm well
and hopefully I you know speak for Ron
at times about these things around which
I mean if I'm not but the the trajectory
of our world can be aligned in a more
positive direction by sharing people and
ideas that do exactly that and so that's
what this program does it shares those
ideas and those people that we think can
help align the trajectory of the plan in
a better direction and as we mentioned
in our first episode prevent the
civilization collapse help with
authentic relating with other people
it's a very multidisciplinary show so
you'll see scientists on your you'll see
entrepreneurs on here you'll see
spiritual leader is on here you'll see
people in the emotional intelligence
space on here and across all different
fields and so that makes it also really
cool for building out a worldview that
has a ton of different perspectives that
is baked into it and the show is yeah a
daily show featuring the different
leaders but it's also live events that
we do it's also us working on bigger
projects that synthesize all the complex
information that we're learning into
both short videos longer films books all
different types of things that we're
working on and you know maybe we hear
some things from Ron to
well question what's our underlying
philosophy behind the show uh-huh yeah
we're like even a little like what is it
that you care about or believe in so
like I heard like aligning the world in
a more positive trajectory but like that
could be more positive in terms of like
politically environmentally socially
technology and inside of those there's a
bigger thing so like what is it that
wakes you up in in the morning and has
you be like yeah this is the thing I
want to change well I have a different
perspective on things because I'm not as
optimistic about the future as Alan is I
feel our the destruction of this
civilization is inevitable granted there
are a lot of evolved humans among us but
I don't think enough for us to
collectively get the lesson our problem
is with acquiesce more than anything
it's about the people that are quiet
when they see something wrong or the
people that will sell out and that's
totally understandable because people
have families to support and if they
have a job that pays really well and
it's not the best ethics you know
they'll still take that job and and
that's the problem among us what wakes
me up in the morning just when I'm no
longer tired and that's that's how I
roll I just you know I don't you know
keep a day job so to speak so I get my
sleep and I'm just living off of Ron Ron
Vargas's brain in his memory and so it's
you know
it's a symphony of souls that inhabit
this body and I have all I can do is
apply it
what I've learned is just to apply it to
myself I've learned in my 52 years that
people will learn on their own they
don't want it you can tell them as much
as you can about the truth but they need
to discover it themselves and we learn
through hardship and the destruction of
this civilization is going to be a big
learning tool for us and we'll rebuild
again and we'll and we'll probably
destroy ourselves again
it's a very long process evolutionary
process the divine source to connect
with the divine source as we're being
you know manipulated and genetically
modified in someone's image that wants
us to believe it's gone when when it's
really not it's no more of a God than
you and I Oh manipulator than genetic
image of someone something that wants to
believe it's God that was beautiful I
don't
III true I don't I don't believe I think
I don't think we evolved to who we are I
think it's a genetic genetic
modification that's why I brought up the
animals earlier in the program this
planet with the living plants and
animals is a beautiful ecosystem big
fish eat little fish Lions don't hoard
hell for chewing on the wildebeest and
if you're a vegan I need to remind you
about the Venus flytrap it eats flies so
so what I'm really curious about now is
like you to almost seem like you lie at
different ends of the spectrum like it
seems like there's some similarity and
like that you think about this on a
wider scale and what is philosophy and
how are we impacted by the environment
and like have a consciousness of
yourself on a wider level but like
they're pretty different worldviews so
like how do you work together mm-hmm
I think that's exactly why it's such a
good combination because Ron teaches me
a lot with what he just said and then I
hope that through some of the things
that I say that Ron also feels like he's
reminded about some of the more positive
optimistic and even at times realistic
and futures that we can develop Ron's 52
I'm 26 so it's you know it's a double
age game to that Ron's been around
longer to see the world evolve twice as
long as I have and because of that he's
seen some things that I have yet to see
and so I'm also trying to pick up as I
talk to people that are older than me on
the show we do our best you know just
fill Boris was just on the show and he's
76 and so he has had he was born in 42
during World War Two and whenever that
happens I mean look you got to remember
like humble yourself kid
like people have had like a lot of life
experience that they're trying to share
with you and with other people on the
program so home-brewed humble yourself
don't let your hubris get ahead of you
and also remember the selfless essence
that you try and carry which is that
this program is not for you it's not for
Ron this program is for other people and
inspiring them to make that trajectory
more positive and this has nothing to do
with fame money greed at all this has
everything to do with people coming
together to build a better world and
that's the main pillar of our ethos that
I at least carry as best as I can and
aim to remind myself of but it is in
very many ways just Ron teaches me a lot
by having a perspective that's different
than mine in many ways but similar to
mine as well
what I love about it is you you both are
like so like articulate and obviously
thought-out in your views that it
actually has me have a lot more respect
for both of you that you allow
yourselves to be influenced by each
other because that's hard like to have
something you care about and to have
other people challenge it and to be like
oh maybe this is a point of information
yeah yeah always treat it like you can
learn from everyone yeah yeah it's a
great dynamic yeah the other thing that
I really like about that is like the
respect for age I've been one of the
topics have been exploring lately as
death and dying and aging and in one of
the conversations I was having with fun
something came up around like there
aren't really good models for age in our
culture like for what it looks like to
age in a way that's generative and
positive for society and also for
yourself or to like take in wisdom from
people that are older and so I'm hearing
that and what you're saying about Vaughn
we also have to be careful with you know
with age there's a lot of examples of
adults that are full of [ __ ] and acting
very juvenile and also you know I'm not
I'm not a parent I'm not a dad but I
just I'm just acknowledging where
parents to have a tendency to teach
their children's stuff to say that they
believe and they want their children to
grow up low like them when you know they
they still have lots of work to do
within themselves I think there's lots
of things that you know parents should
listen to their children you know what I
think they're coming from another place
another understanding I don't believe
that the soul is fresh and children are
born innocent you know they're subject
to the genetic structure of their mom
and dad and then there's who they are
and and all they wanted we all we're all
tasked to be is a more a divine human
being in
disconnected from you know a good
example of just a good current state of
affairs right now you take someone
that's younger and you like Esther
Wojcicki has been on the show and she's
I think she's just turned around 70 ish
as well and her ethos is that working
with kids in Palo Alto in the high
school and journalism and just doing
things like media arts and like for 30
plus years of doing this and if she's
literally hanging out with people that
are between the ages of like 13 to 17 on
a daily basis and hearing their ideas
and she's staying really open-minded to
learning from them that will keep you
young forever to like you have to have a
little bit of like rigidity with like
yeah the kids probably can't publish
like things that are that explicitly
taught a showcase of violence and things
like that but at the same time that if
they are trying to push the edge in some
way for someone like us there to stay
more open-minded and humble to letting
the kids have leadership and direction
that's like when you talk to kids if
you're gonna stay open-minded you may
learn something from a 13 year old an 18
year old a 24 year old that you do not
hear of very often in your circles of
adults and so I think especially with
young people's you can literally see
like Phil look when he was on our show
he was you know finger poking at the
keyboard when he was trying to type
stuff and there's a big difference
between the kids that are like 15 right
now that know how to use technology in
and out seamlessly and so like there's
for sure a lot of information that can
be learned from the kids especially if
they're super hungry in a specific
subject and they're just sponging up and
for knowledge in that subject and then
practicing teaching it to other people
yeah we've had like josh has been on our
show young twenty year old building bio
labs of the future you know what I mean
like this is what we're talking about
really young people that are
the edge of their fields too so stay
humble even to people younger than you
that can teach you things so that's a
it's a big part of the ethos so there is
this this thing that I was playing with
the other day when I was having that
conversation of death and dying and I
was I thought of something called the
god game which is like if you were God
and you could reinvent Society in
whatever way you thought would work best
like same laws of human nature same
structure and all that but you can
reimagine it how would you be imagine
learning it's a good question we asked
the question on the show if you could
rebuild civilization from scratch how
would you do it yes that's one of our
cues - but specifically around learning
like what would you do that's what I
heard you - you said that that's a
little different for sure and you also
kept it in the same natural laws we let
people build with whatever laws they
want off the bat that's cool so same
natural laws
how would you reimagine learning well
first of all one of the most important
things to remember is that the input
stream that you take in is what is what
ends up becoming you so to be very
vigilant with what inputs you take in as
your learning material is critical and
on other things bloom to Sigma so
remembering that if you have a mentor
that you're going to perform two
standard deviations above the mean of
other people that are trying to learn in
like larger class sizes so having
mentorship being very vigilant of your
inputstream having really cool
activities around expanding people's
awareness from the really young ages
when they're born into the world
teaching them about things like deep
time and how we actually got to this
point yeah I'm loving this and just to
make it like even a little bit more
experiential like I'm a kid I am like
just born I'm going like the education
system what happens to me yeah do I get
assigned a mentor like what is just as
kind of a fun thought experiment well
there's definitely something about when
you're like first born into the world
about how to you know I mean I'm I'm not
a fan of being born into hospitals
actually
I'm also you know there's obviously like
there's people like there's there's
tribes like the Kogi tribe that's in
Colombia where the Mamas that are born
are born into caves and then they stay
in capes for their first nine years of
life and they develop their sensitivity
with their connection to spirit the
connection to mother earth their
connection in nature and then by the
time they leave the cave when they're
nine they're ridiculously connected so
yeah being born into hospitals and then
being being like given like
technological devices before like the
child even understands who they
themselves are definitely seems like it
could be a recipe for not as much self
actualization it's okay so you're a
child you're born into the world well
first of all probably be born somewhere
that's not in a metropolis like so
you're born into into like a beautiful
array of trees and Oceanside let's say
and then when you're there like every
day like you're doing things in nature
that provides you with food like you
have to learn how to garden right away
you have to learn how to look at the
Stars and realize how much they dwarf
your own ego and how much how beautiful
it is that we all come from creation and
that all of us are acting as a nerve
endings of creation so if you can
remember those things from the young age
and also like have activities that teach
you those things which you know this is
on the spot I'm doing my best but like
those are I think some of the critical
like activities to go through yeah what
do you think
no that was really beautiful thank you
for that and I got these pictures in my
head of what it would be like to grow up
like that
and I hadn't really we imagined life
outside of being born and going up in a
metropolis and so thinking about like
growing up having a sense of perspective
on myself feeling connected to things
outside myself like Elizabeth Gilbert
has this really beautiful TED talk where
she talks about like how if if she felt
like she was the one responsible for all
her writing she would be so like tense
whenever she wrote and so if she thought
of it as something that came through her
there was this sense of freedom and that
seems like Millie what you're speaking
to is like how do you have freedom by
believing it's not just you
yeah you know Ronde of thoughts on the
education of children when they're born
into the world well I'm not as reluctant
uh yeah I kind of like the metropolis
I'd like to be where the action is I
wouldn't mind being born into the city
but also I understand the importance of
getting away from that city and you
might have a greater appreciate
appreciation for nature if if you you
grow up without it
and then you you you get back to it so
it'sit's and it does it certainly takes
all types you know among us so we can't
all grow up in nature you know some of
us have to be city slickers and why not
because it takes all types so I'm
actually curious for you like if I'm a
kid growing up in your ideal world like
where do I go off and what do I learn
like what are the first lessons good
question your first experiences if he
would and what is the question like what
would I loved about what Allen answered
was kind of like what are the the almost
like the things that get set in your
mind from a young age that influence
everything else so like what are the
experiences or lessons that you would
want every kid to have when they're
really young
every child to have
now it's not for me to say because just
there's so many different opportunities
I mean I just I ran away from home when
I was 12 you know I didn't like what was
what was there you know you may eat awk
tabat your brother earlier and you know
you aren't all that connection he had a
rough childhood you know I kind of had
that with you know all my family looking
at it more like a observer and trying to
adapt and you know trying to use humor
to break things up you know but I didn't
you know just I I saw that myself you
know what I was looking for I obviously
wasn't getting and I just you know tried
to try to break away from that and find
it and I did you know I did I had a
great journey I've done lots of
different things met lots of different
kinds of people and I've learned a lot
and there's still a lot more to learn
but you know as a child it's not really
for me to say what every child should
get in their childhood because I don't
know where they're coming from
you know I know I don't know what with
what they need and
it's another interesting dichotomy is
that Iran's had a very tons of different
experiences in his 52 years and that's
because he like went on a path that was
so much different than what was trying
to be programmed into him and I think
that's really beautiful but this is a
good dichotomy Ron says something like
you know Who am I to say like what it
should be and I'm like I'm pretty
certain that that what I have studied
even in the youthful days that I have so
far is I'm pretty sure it's in it I sit
on the shoulders of giants whatever's
coming through me is sitting on the
shoulders of we're talking a hundred
billion people that have lived and died
before us to build the civilization
their most profound knowledge is is what
I've been studying especially over the
last couple of years of doing the show
and to know that we all come from
creation and to know that of our
interconnectedness and to know of our
own purpose and our own divine calling
that were birth into the world to
achieve like I'm pretty sure that those
two things are the most crucial to start
and then from there there's plenty of
other ways to endeavor but I could say
even a close third one would be to know
what the crew most crucial things are in
the civilization that you're birthed
into so one could view it as this wisdom
race that we talked about in the first
episode where the exponential
technologies are being democratized the
geopolitical situations are being crazy
and so consciousness the level of
consciousness on the planet has to rise
up fast enough to be able to handle that
and another way to view it is like the
United Nations sustainable development
goals so that these are the important
things maybe once you know that we all
come from creation once you know what
your purpose or your most deepest drive
towards meaning is well then there's so
many different things for you to pick
and do
but to be maybe geared more in the
direction of solving the world's most
complex challenges I think is a pretty
good next step after that yeah there's
such a interesting and I'm just a really
loving seeing the way that you all
balance each other and like thinking
about about age a little bit again it's
like like as I get older I keep like
finding things that I think are true and
then they get disproved but I still have
like enough energy and passion to be
like really into the things that I'm
into it's like yeah I actually believe
that authentic relating and better
communication can like take away a lot
of suffering and my goal in the world is
to reduce or human suffering like that's
the thing I care about and I feel like
I've found one path towards it and I
imagine as I get older like I'll try
things
I'll get disproved I'll find that wasn't
really it and there was something else
that like my mom studied epidemiology
which is the study of disease across
population and epidemiology has added
something like 30 years to the human
lifespan in the past 100 on average and
she studied that for years and years and
made incredible contributions to the
field and then when she got older found
that that aging and the way that our
healthcare system deals with it is one
of the biggest problems in society it
was like her work in a way contributed
to that even though on one scale she was
doing something beautiful and so it's
like I imagine where Ron has gotten to
is like having that enthusiasm towards
various things than having it balanced
more and more over time to where now his
like power is that he can give he can
give perspective and feedback on things
and then your power is that you can be
passionate towards things even if it's
not as balanced but like I think we have
to actually have a like more
single-minded perspective to really go
towards something
you're gonna have so many tests of faith
when you have that push like if you want
to make the world a better place if you
want to change it there's gonna be all
different types of tests of faith that
are gonna happen I got a lot of that
when I was challenged to do better you
know the test oh really oh really you
wanna be positive all the time and then
you know you get these challenges and
it's it challenges yourself you know I
went through but I I recall
distinctively you know during my
Epiphany my own revelation that I was
challenged to be you know if I
proclaimed I want to do better and be a
positive influence they they they gave
me a lot to deal with and they I want to
make reference today I have no idea who
they are
and just also mention on our show we
asked questions and the point is that
when we come up with something that we
think is a really good maybe first and
second principle for children to have as
a education around the world our this is
just what we're synthesizing at the time
but really were the ones that are also
as we come up with these ideas of
structures we're simultaneously asking
people for questions on what they think
are the best educational systems what
they think about the one that we have as
an idea so that's that's against such an
important part of the ethos is that it's
not that we have answers actually we
have questions and we're formulating
ideas along the way and then asking
people what their thoughts are on the
ideas I can see why earlier in the show
you said you'd been studying Socratic
dialogue we're really interested in that
yeah I'm curious like what's one one
idea that you've had really changed
since you started this show by doing
some of these interviews like a belief
you held in yourself probably that we
all come from a single source
what does that change too
that's probably been the most important
one that's been changed
you mean beforehand you didn't believe
that and not yeah maybe like end of 2017
early 2018 definitely like a year and a
half ago I wasn't really thinking too
much about that we all come from a
single source
that we all come from creation wasn't
thinking about that so much
you know we had this little taste of
like well okay we all come from the Big
Bang or like sure people have been
playing with different definitions of
the word of God but I wasn't like
piecing together an all my meditative
experience a psychedelic experiences now
all these things piece together more in
us in a way that makes a lot more sense
can you can I can I ask a question Alan
you know you talk about God you know
define reaction you know if somebody I
just out of the blue comes up and just
punches you in your face for no reason
whatsoever I'm challenging you to choose
to explain to me why punching him back
if not punching and punching him to
death so that he doesn't do that again
to anybody how is that not godlike
and furthermore it's say if you want to
you know do the Jesus thing and you know
to turn the other cheek and you do that
and this person that punches you in the
face
the next day kills somebody how how you
gonna feel about that you're gonna wait
for God to fix it yeah these are you
know these are really interesting
questions that it's great that Ron
brings them to the tension of people
because without someone that's willing
to endeavor into asking it like Ron we
would not know how to handle situations
like that the first thing to address
that situation with is the building a
world where that doesn't happen so
that's first and foremost what I'm
passionate about I don't think that's
possible I think the universe is very
violent it's random and when you go to
trying to create a utopia planet of love
it's it's it's it's against the laws of
nature but you switch to my fullscreen
he's good for those watching at home we
both have access to the switch that's
fine but I I do apply love you know I do
believe that love is the answer but we
also talk about tough love and what does
that mean and it's about saying no it's
also about not enabling drug addicts or
or or what not you know you have to say
no and you have to turn your back and
you and you can't worry about it you
can't save we can't we can't save the
world from itself we can't save this
human experiment from itself I believe
that what's behind it it needs to learn
because I think there's something behind
this kind of like us and it keeps itself
a secret and that's what needs to learn
that's what needs to learn we need to
allow if destruction is inevitable so
let it be where these little humans
whatever is behind it all its eternal
the life force and if we're all
connected I could be just multiple hey
rock sources yeah it seems like
something you're really passionate about
like that you have this belief and like
that what you've experienced has what I
heard is like there's like violence in
that and a question of like what is what
is God in that and where does it come
from and like that that's an experience
the God to me is this is the rebellion
that's the rebellion there's something
among us that wants to program us and
what is like to take here Allen's view
on it we haven't even gotten into
something reminds me a lot of my naivete
when I was young and I did I did have a
more optimistic view and belief in love
however you know something is it's
taught me to think otherwise and that's
just that's who I am so there's a cloud
layer it's not for everybody like I I
need to just be me I don't want
everybody to be like me I like Allen and
I are a good example of just these
dynamics working together and respecting
each other yeah and you know if we can
do it then everybody else can do it all
we can do is lead by example like I
can't tell people what they should do
and Allen can't tell people what they
should do but people can look at the
both of us and say okay it works they
respect each other's opinion they
disagree with each other on a different
but on the same note these two men you
know produce a pretty good program
that's whose main focus is just in
creating a better human being I'm
curious if you if you want to hear his
view on it like what his perspective on
this is well I'm 52 years old yeah yeah
I don't you know I've just it's almost
like maybe you you feel like you've
heard the view I have I can't be
persuaded to not be me I still have to
be me
I don't I feel like like a respect and
sadness at the same time I'm not sad
don't be sad I'm happy I do whatever it
takes to deliver life I don't know if I
feel it from you I actually feel it like
there's a sense of like the things in
life that I can't change and the
experiences that I've had like like I
can't change the feeling of growing up
isolated and what that's like led me to
do and believe about the world and the
sense that like no one's gonna save me
if I don't save myself like that's the
fact that I just I I want to like change
my view on it but I believe in it sounds
like there are some of those for you
you've gotten help I'm sure you've
gotten help nobody can't nobody can
you're right nobody can't you have to
save yourself but there is help there's
this help all around you get help and
you either go with it or not and if you
have to learn the hard way so let it be
you know I learned my lesson in love I
learned the hard way and I'm so grateful
for that I would never have understood
love commitment and loyalty respect if I
did not try to love and I have no
regrets of
that it was difficult it was very
painful but I'm a better person for it
nothing I'm and I still have a lot to go
regarding love
curious how you're doing
notice I want to like bring the energy
down it felt like there was like a lot
of intensity and like a lot coming out
and imagine like you're you're holding
something
feel like a little bit in the middle or
wanting to normalize or something
there's some background that I think is
important to give and the background is
directly applicable to every single
person which is that what's happening on
the planet is not just as simple as a
bunch of humans on the planet with the
animals and the plants and the earth
orbiting a star in the galaxy in the
universe and that's the end of the story
and so because of that then we must
probe what is beyond that and we've had
many conversations on the show about
that and Iran has been studying into
that for a while and having his own
experiences with that for a while
I myself have started to have more and
more experiences with that and more
conversations and more reading and
studying about that myself
and so that how we view just the
government's and the education systems
and the media companies and the monies
and monetary systems and the healthcare
systems all different things that exist
on the planet the economy all these
things are at the surface what's beyond
that and who controls that is the next
question
and then what's beyond that and who
controls the people that control those
systems that's beyond even humans is the
next one and it all comes from creation
but then what happens after that what
exists outside of the physical planet
that we live in and the physical
creatures that live on the planet
and so Ron and I have been bronzed been
a major influence on me studying into
that more and learning into a more other
people like Bernard Gunther's been
another major one Robert's family has
recently been one Tom Montauk's been
another one just more and more people
that are pushing into that field of
study do we do are we gonna get table
talk on our show we're gonna aim to get
Tom on the show that's coming up and
even these are people that are alive
today these there are people like Dante
that have been writing about this and
studying about it even Socrates Plato
and Aristotle that have been talking
about and writing about it even before
then and we're not tying 500 or 2,000
years ago we're talking about since the
dawn of civilization there have been
people talking about what the [ __ ] is
happening here that is beyond this
physical understanding what forces come
through me is there a good and an evil
is there are there things like what
people call archons that are evil
spirits and are there things that are
angels that are good spirits are there
are there are those at play within me to
build this world are they competing with
each other to have their own outcome
happen on this rock why does it feel
like the artificial cities that we've
built these metropolis why does it feel
like those in many ways are propagating
what feels to be code that is very
disconnected from what feels to be good
code and why is it when you go into
nature when you go into those depths of
the woods and the oceans that you feel
things that are really true to who you
are and what it is to have this
experience is that potentially showing
us our disconnect from creation so this
is a very long-winded way of just
explaining that this is way more
complicated than just a physical world
it's way more complicated than just the
simulation
yeah it is
hey I can tell it like mine that that
sense of it like that this is more than
just the physical world that like you
were talking about how that's one of the
biggest things that you've learned in
the last couple years and gotten a sense
of and as you're talking about it I'm
like drawn into that and like the
experience that you've had of that
reality and how core that seems to you
right now like it seems like a lot of
what even underlies you wanting to do
this show and what you get from it
yep and that makes me feel very gotten
very understood yeah yeah I'm actually
really impressed with the two of you
like you all have some pretty pretty
different worldviews and to work
together and to like be in that is like
a major test of faith
yeah I know I'm where I'm supposed to be
right now I I'm doing I'm this is my
maximum potential at this point likewise
can you feel that way that I'm living my
maximum potential
I feel like I'm constantly questioning
it every day and in a way like that is
living it like I'm always keeping myself
on the edge of like is this the thing
that I should be doing today is this
what's in my greatest good like could I
be doing more serving more even to the
point of like if I'm taking time off and
like being lazy or like you know I was
at a fusion dance weekend all weekend
and there's the part of me that's like
why aren't you working on stuff like why
aren't you building a newsletter to
connect the different authentic relating
communities to have them share resources
with each other why aren't you studying
how to like help kids in poverty get it
get out of it but like any given moment
it's like what's gonna serve me most and
being the most I can for the world and
how do I do that from the place I'm at
and how do I continuously update even
what I believe like hearing both of
y'all's experiences like those are
things that I don't know as much about
like I don't know what it's like to grow
up and and like not and like not have a
family from a young age or what it's
like to like have a sense of real
universal consciousness like I've tasted
pieces of these things but like I hope I
keep getting impacted and having to
question and
even though sometimes I resent that
questioning and I'm like should I be
spending so much time like should I just
like focus on one thing but it's like
popping out to that wider perspective of
what is the world as a whole and how do
I fit into it that like I think
ultimately makes me better yeah yeah you
got it and you're also very curious in
the first place about what exists and
because of that you're gonna end up
wandering yourself into things just keep
going into the fields that you think are
most pressing and important to you and
if you think of if you feel like what
Ron and I were just talking about a
little bit is very interesting to you
there's a bunch of different places to
go and dive into this that that we can
help and same thing with other people
that are watching so because without
those steps into these categories that
interest us it stays at the surface and
that's an unexamined life and that's not
worth living
but the examine life is also a very
difficult thing because when you start
examining it it becomes a little bit
more as some people use this word
schizophrenic it does it becomes that
way it's like the Heisenberg uncertainty
principle it's like you can't know where
something is and how fast that's moving
at the same time it's like as soon as I
try to pinpoint something down there's
like way more movement that I'm present
to I'm just like oh God where does it
stop yeah yeah yeah that's it it's
elusive it's like trying to grasp water
yeah so it in its in another word that
also explains it is hyper realities
there is a lot of different worldviews
that are currently trying to construct
what is true and what is reality and
what a subjective versus inter
subjective versus objective versus inter
objective all these types of things and
it drives people nuts when they start
trying to pin it all down and that's why
some of the most genius people that have
ever existed before took the most burden
on themselves to completely update the
world around them and they sacrifice
their families they sacrificed their
friends they sacrificed things to do on
the weekends they sacrificed
entertainment they sat but they
definitely didn't sacrifice connection
to themselves they enjoyed solitude they
enjoyed what they wanted to focus on
achieving as the most important thing
and when you do that you can make
updates into the world and those
transcend you and if you're doing it for
ego or fame or money people can smell
that and they will not work with you and
if you do it to transcend you to make
the world better people can smell that
and they will work with you and so make
that like one of your central ideas of
existence is I'm gonna identify myself
with my North Star with the central
pillar of meaning and purpose
and I'm gonna do it in the most selfless
way possible and then that's a good way
to push a code update if you really want
to get to all eight billion people which
is possible it's possible to make the
world a better place it's possible to
try and solve some of the most pressing
challenges on the planet to make sure
we're not a collapsible ization well
then you have to make a lot of
sacrifices and I think like I like your
perspective on the place that comes from
of like you can make sacrifices from ego
of like I'm giving this thing up and I
don't like that and I'm upset about it
and that's the way I'm gonna live out of
like something's making me do this or
it's forced or sacrifices from a place
of like I'm part of something that's
that's evolving that's like I'm like a
molecule in in a cosmos that I get to
contribute to by whatever is happening
to me and whatever is living through me
and even if that's just a perspective
shift there's part of me that that finds
it really relieving to take in
information and then just kind of relax
around it and go like okay what brings
me joy day-to-day and like can that be
the thing that I want to do for the
world
in another place where Ron and I
disagree
likely disagree on and many other people
that watch probably side with one of the
two sides on this is I think it's a very
clear distinction between the right hand
path and the left hand path in terms of
going back to source
and connecting back with this god of all
that is many people say that this right
hand path of pursuing things like
meditation or like deep inner self work
in your path to divinity is what is most
pure and most clean on your ascend back
and other people say [ __ ] that I'm gonna
pursue all different other types of [ __ ]
which is this left-hand path which is
I'm gonna use all different types of
drugs I'm going to use all different
types of material sensations and
pleasures any type of like
overindulgence until any types of of
sensations and desires and that type of
thing and people choose to ascend
towards all that is in that regard and I
think there's a very clear distinction
between the two I think other people
think that there's a very big blur
between the two and that you can ascend
however you want and I think it's very
clear and you can see this with the
trajectories of think about it how often
has a drug like alcohol helped people
reach a state of divinity with God
versus how often has it just destroyed
people's lives and so I think it's
crystal clear
yeah I could see the the perspectives on
it and like it's it almost comes back to
that like the idea that we talked about
in the show of like if if a hundred
people if like two of them are gonna be
are going to be Psychopaths or like in
this case like if two people that drink
alcohol are going to reach divinity
through it that couldn't any other way
like is it worth the ninety-eight that
might actually have negative impact on
their life by doing it or it seems like
what you're looking for is like is there
a path that more reliably might get you
to a place of transcendence even if the
other one might be possible and some
people might get there through
acceptance of their own desires which is
kind of the dichotomy in my work like if
you focus on authenticity you're
including things like people's desire to
drink people's desire to like thank you
yes it's it's a part of people and the
more that we I think to me divinity
often occurs as like how do I accept the
most parts of myself and other people
because there's this like weird thing
that happens where when I accept it all
of a sudden it has less of a hold on me
and it's like if I'm drinking alcohol
it's probably coming from something
where like oftentimes for me it's it's
like it can be like okay I just want to
like have a beer and I'm enjoying the
taste I'm and drink it over the course
of an entire evening to where it doesn't
affect me much which is usually it and
then sometimes it's like I'm feeling
like such a pain or a loneliness or
something that I want to like take the
edge off of it and feel something
different and then if I if I shame that
part of me if I if I push it away then I
end up having like more drinks because I
want to like dole the shame and then I
get caught in this cycle of like you
know I'm not okay the world's not okay
like something's wrong here and I've
been really exploring this idea of how
can I like see what I'm doing and just
relax a little bit around it so like
okay have this desire let me sit with it
if I'm gonna do something if I'm gonna
drink can I actually enjoy the taste of
it can I feel this in my body
can I feel where I am
the world's like I was here on Sunday I
was at a dance event and have a really
hard time being away from my community
on Sundays it's the day when like all my
friends go to ecstatic dance and there's
authentic relating games in the evening
and I see all the people that I love and
when I'm in a foreign city it's like I
don't know practically anybody and
there's this like really deep like
longing like I want to like feel that
connection back home and
like one of the things that makes me
want to do is like you know let me let
me just like go and get like a pastry to
eat and just like feel something that
feels good in my body to like fill that
space and in this case I was like okay
I'm gonna I'm gonna let myself do that
but I want to wait an hour and I want to
like actually feel like this longing is
gonna come up again and again it comes
up every time I travel like there's not
a getting away from it so like yes let
me let me do the thing that makes me
feel good but let me also experience the
thing that's happening and there was
actually a real beauty in like feeling I
think it was one of the first times I'd
actually sat with like that pain really
consciously and felt it and felt it as
something that wasn't gonna go away and
then when like goddess cone and ate it
and called a friend and like by the time
I did both of those together I actually
felt really settled in myself and I
think if I'd missed either one I
actually would have deprived myself of
something
sounds like balance to me
Sara keep up the good work we're all
counting on you ha ha no one here gets
out alive before you know it yep life's
a terminal game the snarl your own movie
if you take something like that example
and you dig deeper into it uh-huh
the elders from around the world have
been saying this for a long time and
it's directly related to what I said
about educating children when they're
born into the world that if the spirit
of the child does not get connected to
nature does not get create connected to
creation and to their divine purpose
from a young age what the elders say is
that then their spirit becomes
fragmented mm-hmm when the spirit is
fragmented then people feel a void I'm
saying this from a position of privilege
where I feel pretty strongly like I'm
really working on making it so that I'm
not free fragmented and that I'm
connected to divine source at all times
but that's a position of privilege other
people from around the world say that
when you're born into a village and you
have indigenous people around you that
are constantly working with you on that
that that is is that a position of
privilege or is it that we've built
artificial artificiality into our human
experience which has caused the spirit
to be fragmented which then enables what
many people say the evil to come through
us into filling those fragments with
material pleasures with desires with
instant gratification with sensations
and that can we find literally slow down
enough with our decision making to say
okay it's during the day I've traveled
to somewhere around the world
I don't feel connected right now
what if I practice some sort of a deep
connection to my own spirit to my own
meditation to this land to this
beautiful place that I'm in what if I
did that for a couple minutes what would
change and then if you practice that and
do it and something changes in you which
it is likely to change then you may not
need to fill yourself with something
that is something sugary or sweet or
something that is and the evening when
you're alone to need to go and drink to
fill something but rather to go and
explore something within yourself
further or within the knowledge of
society or within your own creative
explorations into the world mm-hmm yeah
it feels it feels true it's like
something I I often question like what
path I take in it so I'll say like for
myself like I have a really hard time
finding a sense of Center like I noticed
that a lot of my identity feels outside
of me like I feel emotions some people
really strongly I get really strongly
affected by my environment even the
clothes I wear totally change how I feel
day to day and for me meditation is
often like a really painful process that
actually feels like closing my eyes cuts
me off of my source of identity and it's
something that I've like been working to
sit with more and but the other thing
I've been working totally does yeah I
imagine it's the same way for a gorgeous
yeah and sometimes like I love it
and sometimes it's like the pain
actually feels super valuable and and it
was actually something that I was doing
like when I was first feeling that like
akin and longing and
I guess something that I've been trying
to explore in the last couple years is
is there a way for everyone to reach
beauty from the place that they are and
men are there multiple paths like if for
some people meditation is a path like
for other people is it awareness of the
stuff that they're doing further and and
even like considering different
personality types like if I teach a
training there's always some people that
want to hear more teaching and some
people that want more experience and I
want to say like I'm more on the side of
experience like y'all just like do the
experiential thing like you'll learn the
practices by doing it just do it and
then I find out that there are people
that like actually don't learn that way
like they need to hear a teaching they
need to watch something like this which
I have a really hard time watching
videos there's I don't learn
auditorially very well I have to do
something else with my hands like even
while I hold phone meetings I'm usually
rock climbing like I can't I can't like
like just sit still and listen I'm too
kinetic and I've been like trying to
expand like what are the different ways
of making myself the best version of me
and making other people the best version
of them
and and like the I definitely want to
explore more of like what happens if I
just sit with myself
and what happens if I like do the thing
that I want to and stay present to it
and like which of those actually gets me
closer to like the goal that I want so I
appreciate that thought and I'd actually
loved the resources that you have
totally yeah and your perspective is
fantastic as well on the issue David
Alexander English said this on our show
though one of the ultimate creations of
source is a location where people can
feel the illusion of separation from
source which is planet Earth yes so just
leave it at that beautiful leave it as
that would you be the best we can and
these these discounts of personality
these meat puppets you know living our
consciousness our soul doing the best we
can with the brain yeah and and and
thank you Sarah for I hope Allen heard
your words you know I think Allen's
pushes more towards like an alien gray
human species where everybody looks the
same and everybody's the same I don't do
that at all not at all that's not me
whatsoever on and we have a little bit
of work to do you know because you're
because that's so binary that's going to
one extreme and labeling me with that
that's horrible no everyone has a no to
labeling expression to express
themselves at creatively in the world
and to be able to have that happening
who takes a lot of work to develop
society to make it so that every child
that's born into the world can actually
develop themselves to their fullest
creative expression and potential and so
that's what I'm getting at and that
takes a lot of work with the social
fabric to do that in a couple of the
first principles to get there are one a
deep connection to all that is to source
to nature first second understand
yourself understand yourself and your
own purpose and your
meaning there's not a prescriptive path
towards principle 1 or principle - not
at all
hit the nail on the head never ever say
that about mere and I mean even other
people I don't think anyone on the
planet wants everyone to be the same
that's horrible when you talk about
alcohol being yeah you know fried and
fragmented Souls
I feel good in myself I don't you know I
don't I don't think I'm doll that
indulgent and you know but bet she's
balanced you know this is my Shores and
I'm gonna live it before I'm dead and I
just don't want to hurt anybody and this
is me and you're you and you know this
is where we all have to kind of work
together you know maybe they'll be down
the road on the planet or it's different
places that you can go like Fantasy
Island from the 70s are kind of dating
myself on this show but they used to be
a show in the 70s where people could go
and experience things that they just
wanted to experience maybe we'll
establish that on this planet if all the
people that want to just for a second I
think I think both of what you're saying
is valid but I'm noticing that like
y'all are seem like you're hitting some
pretty deep nerves in each other like
each other it's like core way of life
and your beliefs around it which seem
like they are different like y'all hold
different beliefs and they might not
reconcile and
I understand that right yeah I'm good
with that but I think that like in what
you're saying like you're actually
hitting on something that really matters
to Alan and I imagine that he actually
like feels like his way of being is
being judged even as you feel like yours
might be judged by like the idea that
that alcohol might not be welcome it's
like for him it's like his idea that
divinity is especially I'm a
troublemaker
yeah I'm the devil's advocate in this
place I mean that's that's my role right
so but I'm apologetically
where are you going with that with that
like I'm just noticing you two like it
seems like there's these moments where
you're like hitting like values and
identity which is like different than
like kind of top-level conversation and
feelings but it's like for you it's like
there's actually an identity and a value
around like the oneness of being in our
capacity to become that which isn't
exclusive I think of ron's of wrongs
like kind of what feels like I'm more
grounded like like day to day and like
how he's built himself and how he
experiences others it's almost like like
Earth and heaven but like where your
your views are or where you're like
focuses is different and I think you're
actually inclusive of each other's views
but when you're talking you're not like
affirming it first so it's like even
though I think you see each other it's I
think you both feel like the others way
of being is being attacked and I'm
wondering if that's if you feel like
attacked sometimes when when one is
speaking if there's something where you
feel like he's missing you and what you
care about
I'm just speaking really kind of openly
I enjoyed the way that you're speaking
about it it's great to have another
someone else here that's able to view
this dialog and then add their own
perspective to it I think that's
extremely helpful and I think what you
said is really insightful
I'm curious if like if you understand
Vaughn's point of view like if if it
makes sense to you it's so difficult to
be able to say one understands another
person's point of view I can say that I
think Alan
he done he does understand where I'm
coming from and he accepts that and
respects that and that's a that's what
without that this this couldn't happen
the same thing in return
yeah what do you yeah Ron I'm curious
what you understand about Alan's point
of view like what do you think he's
standing for well I know he wants to we
both want to see a better human being
but in order to to achieve that you know
we have to respect the difference and
what it is to be a human we're all
different I don't want to be all the
same like I didn't you know in the army
you know they they they shave your head
they give you all the same uniform and
they all want you to stop stop stop stop
stop this is leading to a straw man and
let's not go down this because it's not
actually what I represent whatsoever so
a straw man is when you misrepresent
someone else's point to make it easy to
defeat I never once said that I want
everybody to be the same so let's not
even go in that direction so this is
they weren't necessarily aware watch
Alan to be able to finish his sentence
just because it seems like the tensions
getting high again so you you to like
feel like your perspective is more
nuanced and like there's kind of a black
and white and you're like okay some of
the nuances getting missed in that
yeah that's why the middle my middle
name was changed across all the social
platforms to nuance because by
showcasing that word more frequently in
the spheres that people most frequently
occupy which is now the internet sphere
and they see that word more and more
often they'll be like will become kind
of like a subconscious program into the
word nuance and wanting that to to that
for that to be a little bit more of a
central part of their lives
rather than in this scenario I think it
was clearly evident that there was a
misrepresentation of someone's point of
view to make it easier to defeat and
that's so you feel like it got it got
simplified and nuance is something that
really matters to you yeah that's why
FINRA no names now yeah that's a pretty
big change to make for something you
believe in yeah and I think that it's
okay because you know I what I first
said to Ron was that I don't know his
perspective I don't know your
perspective I don't know any of the
eight billion people's perspectives I
don't know any of the animals
perspectives or even gaius this move
doesn't spirit of Mother Earth's
perspective I'm only doing my best to
try and understand it and so when you
can really embody the words I know I
know nothing when you can really embody
those words and I just I know nothing
just that's it you can start there and
when you embody that then you don't do
things like accidentally strawman
people's perspectives or you don't do
things that are at times you can think
that you're doing something that's
really beneficial but if you just take a
step back and slow down and just humble
yourself a little bit more like you
can't say that you know life 25 50 75
years and you shouldn't say that you
know nothing because then you're going
to be subject to
good governance and to follow and to be
as one that has nothing to do with
divine source I know I don't know
everything Alan but I'm not gonna say
that I dare not say I know nothing I
know nothing acts as a metaphor and that
metaphor is to humble people I know
nothing is not an actual statement of I
know nothing because everything in your
life that you've experienced up until
this point is that you know you know
what where you know where you were born
on this planet you know who your mom and
dad are most likely you know these types
of things you know these things you know
what you ate for lunch or breakfast or
whatever today right so these are the
straw man argument I'm bringing up a
very nuanced point of view right now
which is actually that you know things
you know things but to say you know
nothing is a metaphor for life and the
importance of saying that it humbles you
humbles you that's it
this has been beautiful yeah thoughts I
am getting a little tired so I think I
want to end after this okay
thoughts
I want to find a way of y'all like so so
my like predisposition is like let me
find a way for y'all to see for you guys
to see each other's perspective and like
how there's beauty in each but like I
have a bias towards inclusivity and it's
like maybe y'all's perspectives actually
are different in the creative tension
between you two is like mathematicians
that solve problems more because they
like are pretty intense with each other
that's what it feels like for sure yeah
and like I think that just that there's
there's a moment where like I feel like
both of y'all are like like even right
now like somewhat high activation like I
imagine there's just intensity happening
in both of you I'm not sure but like I
feel it in me and to me that's like a
sign that
I think I'd want you all to like make
sure that you hear each other when the
intensity gets high or just like maybe
take a break for a second because I
think in those moments it's it's really
hard to hear the other person he doesn't
take it personally or totally yeah yeah
yeah these are things that like yeah
it's a very beautiful thing actually
more people around the world did exactly
that it actually helped the world out go
out and about on your own and come back
yeah it's kind of like this time out the
t2t the time out that's what's so cool
about that though is it's like it's like
this idea of like you can get to
transcendence through anywhere like you
can get to transcendence through
conflict and through full expression or
you can get to it through like owning
your experience and seeing other
people's point of views without violence
right exactly I think when you start out
with an argument and then you end up in
violence then that's a different thing
yeah I was literally about to say the
word intelligently so that's not in this
case that's what that is I like what you
said about creative people that are able
to clash just enough where they can help
make themselves even more creative
expressed into the world that's
definitely what it feels like it's a
very beautiful thing and if this
wouldn't happen right if there weren't
Ron's challenging Allen's and Allen's
challenging Rollins and Sarah's seeing
both perspectives and stuff if this
wasn't happening you got to remember
that it would just be that same
perspective which would be so boring it
was actually in the second show
simulation ever did with Joon Yoon it
was a live event we did in December of
2017 with Joon Yoon he has two words we
asked him you know what will happen
immediately after world peace and he
said civil war ten and he said that he
said that because of key words mimetic
general axe
mimetic parallax which means that the
two ideas and
to be competing against each other for
progress even if you have a utopia there
will be at least one another party that
says it will become a better utopia if
we do this additional thing to it or if
we make this additional change to it so
that's the idea of parallax and that's
what we get here is parallax to try and
move things forward there's a great a
great story that it reminds me of of
like the Zen master who has a disciple
that's like constantly like just like
challenging things and not coming to to
like meditations and like never doing
his work and like you know kind of
always causing a little bit of chaos in
the system and at some point the
students come to the master and they say
like pastor like why do you keep this
guy around like how can you allow him to
like stay at the monastery and the
master goes oh him I pay him mm-hmm yeah
this is a good show good show good wrap
you yep thanks Sara for coming on for
round 2 so immediately after the first
one it was a lot of fun I really
appreciate you coming on again yeah
thank you both for being so open yeah
yeah we love we love stuff like this is
great and you were the one that said hey
can I ask you some questions this is
about you and then afterward if you want
to we can do it which we did I'm very
grateful we did that thank you everyone
for tuning in we greatly appreciate you
love to hear your thoughts in the
comments blow on what we talked about
this episode it was a really interesting
one to hear your thoughts in the
comments below on and again check out
all the information there Sara's
authentic revolution check all that out
those links are in the bio below and
yeah we're on vog is produced and
directed thank you again Ron and also
support us if you want more cool
conversations like this happening
support I support the artisan entre
spiritual leaders in your area support
them all our links are below
and go and build the future everyone
manifest those dreams since the world we
love you very much thanks for tuning in
we'll see you soon peace
[Music]